animals are known to travel the world on
makeshift rafts synthetic or natural
this is not a frequent thing most coasts
have pretty different animals and plants
from one to the next but the 2011
Japanese tsunami caused a mega rafting
event and scientists were able to track
objects that traveled as far as 7000
kilometers as the water left Japan's
eastern shore it brought with it a
panoply of debris millions of objects
ranging in size from tiny plastic
fragments to whole fishing boats under
the water the debris field became home
to diverse marine life as ocean currents
wept these objects away they took their
inhabitants with many making their way
all the way to the eastern Pacific with
all these animals and detritus on the
move the Japanese tsunami provided a
unique opportunity to track and evaluate
the fate of a biologically rich debris
field debris with living Japanese marine
species began landing on the shores of
the eastern Pacific in 2012 as far north
as Southwest Alaska and as far east as
Central California researchers have
documented animals on 635 debris objects
including docks buoys pieces of wood and
even fishing vessels they found at least
279 living Japanese invertebrate and
fish species none of which have been
reported to have rafted between
continents before many debris objects
were categorized as high richness
arrivals meaning that they carried more
than 20 species
this rigidus may be attributed to the
large amount of non biodegradable
material available for rafting we're
ganna crafting materials such as trees
and root masses have far shorter lives
at sea when compared to synthetic
materials such as fiberglass or
polystyrene longer at sea x means
barnacles limpets and mussels can
establish colonies that can span
multiple generations now we know from
this study of the mega rafting
engendered by the Japanese tsunami just
how far they will go as the world's
population grows the amount of waste
entering the ocean will rise and that
means in the future our coasts could
become a lot less diverse as more
animals hitch a ride
[Music]
[Music]